[MUSIC PLAYING]
BOWEI DU: Welcome
to our session,
Scalable and Manageable, A Deep
Dive into GKE Networking Best
Practices.
Because we all know how perhaps
unnecessarily complicated
networking can be,
we kept the title
of the session long
and dry instead
of making a brief and simple.
Hi my name is Bowei I'm an
engineer on GKE networking
MAHESH NARAYANAN: Hi, my
name is my Mahesh Narayanan,
and I'm a product
manager in GKE as well.
So the format of this session
is going to be a bit different.
Bowei and I get
on a lot of calls
with customers talking
about the issues,
design and architectural
considerations, product
overview, so on and so forth.
So what we've done is we've
encapsulated the customer
questions, and
we're going to try
to come up with the solutions
and recommendations and best
practices that addresses
those questions.
The idea or the
aim of this session
is to look under the
hood at the engine of GKE
and look at the different
advanced cluster management
options and fine
tune this engine.
Some housekeeping.
If you have any questions
about the session,
please go to the Dory
Q&A. It's an internal tool
that we have use
quite a lot in Google,
and it gives an opportunity
for everybody to ask questions.
If you like a
question, please upvote
so that it has a higher
probability of it being asked.
OK.
So you start off
dabbling with GKE,
our a powerful orchestrator
and cluster management service.
As you spend more time,
your confidence grows,
your skillset grows,
you start building
more and more
mission-critical applications
and migrating them to GKE.
GKE clusters start seeing
more and more traffic.
Soon enough your cluster
size gradually starts
growing to a point where you
start running into scalability
and manageability issues.
These issues can
often be avoided
by following best practices
and guidelines from day one.
So that's the crux
of this session.
We often hear from our
customers that they
run into routes quota.
As somebody approving
quota requests,
we see a lot of increase in
quota requirement because
of GKE route space clusters.
Laying out your VPC is
the most important facet
of deploying GKE clusters.
One of the key binary
decisions that needs to be made
is whether you're going to use
routes-based cluster or VPC
native clusters.
Now what are these?
Kubernetes mandates
port-to-port connectivity.
And when a part is talking
to another part in a node,
it uses the bridge interface
to make that happen.
But across nodes, you need
some support from networking
to make that happen--
both overlay and underlay.
So GKE started off with
route space cluster.
And what it did was
it used static route.
So it uses static route.
The nodes used a static
route and announced itself
as a next hop to all
the parts that it hosts.
It's fine for a small cluster,
but as your cluster size
grows, your routes,
quota also increase,
requirements also increase.
So in anticipation of growing
clusters, what we did was we
came up with VPC
native clusters,
which are under
the hood uses alias
IP, which basically
is using secondary IP
on its interface-- on a NIC.
Now VPC native mode
is enabled by default.
And the biggest advantage
over route space cluster
is that it doesn't require
that many routes quota.
Apart from scaling,
as the name suggests,
it also natively increase
integrates with VPC Fabric,
allowing other functionalities
and features like shared VPC,
private clusters, flexible IP
management, snooping checks,
so on and so forth.
So let's talk about
IP management.
Most often the
deployments are blocked
not because of some
fancy new feature,
but because of lack
of contiguous IPs.
And I've been on many
calls with customers
where they have a spreadsheet
with IP inventory,
and they're trying to match
the scale of their cluster
with IPs.
So let's look at IP
management from GKE.
What are some other
resources that use these IPs.
And what are some of the
options to reduce IP utilization
on GKE?
So Kubernetes itself
uses IPs liberally.
Right?
The different
resources-- so before we
get into IP
optimization, let's look
at what other different
resources that uses IP.
That are three resources
that require IPs--
your ports, your nodes,
and your services.
So the nodes use the
primary range of a subnet,
the ports use a secondary
range of a subnet,
and the service also uses a
secondary range of a subnet.
The service and the port second
range need to be different.
We don't allow you to use
the same secondary range.
Now, what are the advantages of
having separate ranges for all
these resources?
There are a few advantages.
The first is it
is more intuitive.
If you have any network security
policies and from a tracking
perspective, it's much easier
to have separate ranges.
You can grow each
resource independently.
And lastly, you
know, if you want
to apply any security
policy based on CIDRs,
it's also easier.
So VPC native provides two modes
of IP allocation to resources.
One is the auto IP mode where
we take care of everything.
GKE's responsibility to allocate
IPs to the different resources,
and it takes care of ensuring
there is no IP overlap.
The drawback is that we
assume certain cluster size--
we assume a moderate
cluster size--
and end up taking an IP block
based on that assumption.
However, if you are
building a smaller cluster,
you know, you want
finer grain control,
you can use a custom
IP option where
you can decide the subnet,
you can decide the range,
and reduce your
overall IP utilization.
One other way of reducing
your IP utilization
is using the primary
range and the second range
for ports across
different clusters.
Right?
We don't allow the
secondary range for services
to be shared across
different clusters,
but for the port primary
and for the port secondary
and for the node
primary, you can share it
across different clusters.
And last, but not
the least, there
is a new node that we added
called max ports per node.
So let's talk about that.
This is feature that
just went into beta.
So to understand the
crux of this feature,
let's define port
density as the number
of ports running per node.
So we talked about
how you define
a port cluster or a port range,
which allocates IPs to all
the ports in your cluster.
But since the node is
actually running those ports,
the nodes need to carve out
a specific or a smaller CIDR
from this oral cluster.
Right?
So with port and
city-based config,
we have kind of opened up
this option to the customer.
You decide how many ports
you're going to run per node.
And thereby the node carves
out that many eyepiece
from the bigger block.
So as an example, let's say
you give a /24 all your ports
in a cluster, and you're trying
to run eight ports per node,
we take a /28 from
that overall /20.
You know, so your /20
exhausts more slowly.
You might ask why are we taking
a /28 if it is only eight
clusters and not /29?
That's because we take
double the amount of IPs
for avoiding issues
like IBD reallocation
when the node goes up and down.
So this is an example of how you
can create a smaller cluster.
Nodes per cluster, 12, so
you take a /28 for that.
Services, you're planning to
run 20 services on this cluster,
so you take a /27 for that.
And the cluster port range
that you define is a /24.
Now you define like as we
talked about ports per node.
You say every node is going
to have eight ports per node
so that's /28.
And there are 16 /28s.
So you are good from all the
different scaling perspective.
Right?
You have slash /28,
which gives you 16 IPs,
32 IPs for services, and 16
/28, so you're good to go here.
So switching tracks from
container native networking
and from IP management, let's
look at network security.
The summary of the ask
is that a customer wants
a completely isolated cluster.
Right?
They want to access
Google services privately.
They might have few
workloads, which needs
to access third-party APIs.
And for that, they need
a deterministic IP.
And they want a
deterministic IP,
because the
third-party vendor has
a whitelist/blacklist
policy, which
requires a deterministic IP.
Right?
So how do you meet
this requirement?
You run something called
GKE private clusters.
And in GKE private clusters,
we take away any public IP,
and it's basically
isolated from the internet.
Now I want to
clarify that when I
say it's isolated
from the internet,
you can still configure an
ingress or a service type load
balancer and allow incoming
traffic to the cluster
from the internet.
So based on this
slide, there are
three steps to take to
isolate your cluster.
First is choosing
the cluster type.
We have primarily a public
or a private cluster.
Depending upon your requirement,
you can choose between the two.
You can expose the
cluster master.
And cluster master
is basically where
we host the [INAUDIBLE] API
server, the [INAUDIBLE],,
and you know, scheduler as well.
So that is in your
control as to how
you're going to expose that.
And then white listing access
to that cluster master.
Network security is a
shared responsibility
in that it's our
responsibility to secure
the sick the Manage Element.
But it's your responsibility
or the user's responsibility
to ensure that they are using
the right option to kind
of lock down the cluster master
as well as the local nodes.
Now in a private cluster,
as I was talking about,
there's only RFC 1918 addresses.
There's no public IP.
Right?
And this by default prevents it
from talking to the internet.
In private clusters, we turn
on private Google access
by default, which means you
can access any of the *.
Google APIs privately.
But if you will
have a requirement
for certain workloads
to go out, you
can also integrate Cloud NAT.
So you can provision a
Cloud NAT and integrate GKE
cluster with the Cloud
NAT functionality.
Second step is exposing the
cluster master endpoint.
So here you have two options.
You can create a
private endpoint, which
gives a private IP to
the cluster master,
and this can be used
to access from on prem.
If you have a kubectl
planned over there,
you can use that
private endpoint
to access from on prem.
You can also expose
a public endpoint,
and this is especially useful
for road warrior use cases
where you have a
remote worker who wants
to access a cluster master.
However, you expose
the public endpoint,
it's also accessible to any
untrusted actor as well.
So what we do is we give you
whitelisting, blacklisting--
you know, the white
listing facility
through authorized network
with which you can decide you
can allow the trusted and
disallow the untrusted.
So just to summarize--
I want to talk more about
the authorized network,
but before that, let
me summarize what
we have discussed thus far.
So there is public endpoint
and private endpoint
for accessing the
cluster master.
And in public clusters, you
get only a public endpoint.
In private clusters,
you can have-- you know,
by default, it gives
you a private endpoint,
and it also can extend a
public endpoint [INAUDIBLE]
for road warrior use cases.
Whitelisting through
the authorized network
that I was talking about
there is a default behavior,
and there is another
behavior when you enable it.
I'm not going to go through
go through the table,
but there is a
lot of flexibility
in terms of different
permutations and combinations
that we support to meet
your security and compliance
requirements.
DNS Scaling.
So kube-dns a service that is
used for within the cluster
name resolution.
Kube-dns deployment logic
takes into account the size
of the cluster, but it doesn't
take into account the number
of requests--
DNS requests that
might be going across.
Right?
So the kube-dns lookup
takes up contract entry.
You might have a use case there.
It's a small enough cluster,
but a very chatty application,
which is exhausting
your contract table
which can lead to issues.
So what you can do
is use DNS autoscaler
to modify the number of
business backends that will run.
And this by default,
the equation
takes into account the number of
nodes and number of total cores
across the cluster.
So what you can do
is you can override
that if you say that, hey,
this is a small cluster.
I'm not satisfied with the
number of default backends
I'm getting, you can increase
the [INAUDIBLE] number
of backends or you know, DNS
replicas that you want to run.
As an example, let's say,
you know, you have 10 nodes,
8 cores per nodes-- so total 80
cores running in the cluster,
so by default, you are getting--
because of the function--
the logic-- you are
getting two DNS replicas,
but because the min
setting that you had,
you bumped it up to five.
Right?
So that's another way you can
get over the contract issues.
As you may know, there
are some applications
that are heavy users of DNS--
you know, node.js an example.
If you have control over the
name that they resolve to,
you can avoid search
path extensions.
One of them is through
the application itself
that is pointed out in the top.
And the other one is through
making changes to the pod spec.
So with that, I'll
hand it over to Bowei.
BOWEI DU: So let's now
talk about running services
at scale.
So at first, you
may start off using
an in-cluster-based
ingress controller, which
just uses an
ordinary proxy server
and uses service type load
balancers to expose it
to the internet.
You know this is really
familiar for a lot of us.
It's just the standard
proxy that you
will run on your
laptop and then you
would expose your application to
the internet using service type
load balancer.
However, when your
application scales up,
will really want to use the
Google ingress implementation
in Kubernetes engine.
This is a
container-native ingress
that's globally scalable,
low latency, distributed
proxy layer.
It has lots of built-in features
like caching, authentication,
DDOS protection.
You won't have to
fiddle with figuring out
how many instances of
your proxy to scale to
or how to worry about
absorbing an attack.
But in addition to this,
what are some best practices
around using services?
So first let's talk
about seamless services.
Production services often
require software updates
and upgrades, and ideally,
without disrupting
to your users.
Kubernetes engine gives
you a bunch of nods
to ensure that your services
are updated without impact.
But how these pieces
interact can be subtle.
Let's walk through
each of these pieces
to understand how
they fit together
to ensure that your users won't
see network hiccups as you
scale and update
your applications.
OK.
Let's talk about a pods
lifecycle, particularly
focusing how the pod
lifecycle relates to services.
So there are three
basic states that
govern how your pod
interacts with your services.
First, there is liveness.
This determines whether
or not your pod is up.
For instance, if your pod
fails, it's liveness check,
it will be restarted.
The second bit is readiness.
This determines whether
or not your pod is fully
booted up and healthy and
ready to serve traffic.
For instance, this is
used by workload managers
such as a deployment
resource to see
if it's OK to continue
updating your application.
Finally, there
are health checks.
These come from the load
balancer infrastructure itself
in our end-to-end checks of both
network and application health.
OK.
So let's walk through what
a pod lifecycle looks like
and how to ensure no
service disruption.
So this diagram depicts a
timeline of the pod status.
We have a line for each of
the three states, liveness,
readiness, and health check.
First, we start the pod.
It should be alive.
If it wasn't alive
it would be dead.
So then that would be
end of the story OK.
So next comes health
check and readiness.
Now these can go green
independent of each other.
But when they go green, your
pod will start seeing traffic.
The load balancer will be
sending traffic to your pod.
Now your pod is
running for a while,
and you do an update
of your deployment.
Here is when your pod is
going to be terminated.
What the system will do is
send your pod a sick term.
If you don't handle it,
your pod simply ends here.
However, as you can see, it's
still serving some traffic.
So you will drop some
requests on the ground.
If you do handle it,
then what you should do
is start filling the
health check in readiness.
What this will do is
tell the load balancer
to start draining the
traffic off of the pod.
Finally, after a
fixed amount of time,
Kubernetes will finally
send the SIGKILL,
which will kill your
application for good.
So how do we have
seamless services?
Let's recap.
So the most important thing
is when Kubernetes sends you
a sick term, you have to start
draining your application.
Requests may still be in
flight to your application,
but no new ones
will arrive there.
Now the way to tell the load
balancer that this is happening
is to fail the health checks
and the readiness probe.
Second thing is after
termination grace period
seconds, your pod will
be killed with SIGKILL.
Now if you don't
set the setting,
its default is 30 seconds.
But if your application
takes longer than 30 seconds
to service the
last few requests,
make sure you
adjust the setting.
Finally, sending
these grace periods
may impact how fast a
deployment can update.
So make sure you tune
your deployment mach surge
and max unavailable parameters
to take into account for this.
For instance, if you
can only tolerate
having one pod being
upgraded at a time,
then your upgrade of
your whole deployment
will proceed only
one pod at a time
and will have to wait
for the grace period.
Oh, yes.
And one more thing, if
you have infrastructure
that needs to be integrated
into your pod lifecycle,
that does not necessarily
come from your pod itself--
for example, you have to as
part of pod startup, talk
to a network load balancer,
program the load balancer,
and then inform the pod about
the load balancer's condition,
there's a feature called
pod readiness gates, which
lets you add these custom
conditions from outside
of Kubernetes back into
your pod lifecycle.
So how does this work?
Well, here's your pod lifecycle.
And we see that the
readiness gates actually
slot in the readiness
condition at the front.
So one concern
that you have when
you scale your
backends to thousands
is that of load balance.
In the ideal case, you
want your request traffic
to be evenly distributed
across your backends.
So here is a situation
that actually has come up
a few times that we've seen
is suppose I have a load
balancer with a backend, or
two back ends in this case,
and traffic is flowing.
And I have traffic
to my backends.
And now, I want to
scale up my application.
Now I have four back ends.
And we see that when we send
traffic to these back ends,
it's actually preferentially
going to the older backends.
So why is this?
And is random shuffle
not actually random?
So we know that
Kubernetes and the load
balancer uniformly
randomly sends requests
across all the backends.
So what's going on?
To answer this question,
let's zoom in and see what's
happening.
Let's take a deeper
look to see what
the infrastructure looks like.
So at the top, we
have Google Cloud
load balancer and kube-proxy.
Now requests are
balanced to the nodes.
In fact their balance evenly.
But the kube-proxy then balances
connections to the pods.
So if you see here,
we've scaled up.
We added a few more connections.
But when the requests
come in, traffic
is actually evenly
balanced to the VMs.
But-- and this is especially
true for newer protocols like
HTTP/2--
there is a significant
connection reuse
and requests will
actually likely
go to older backends causing
an imbalance of requests.
So how do we fix this?
So really there is a
disconnect between connections
and requests.
So what to do?
Well, there's two options.
One of them is complex.
So you can modify the
backend to return headers
indicating the connection
should not be reused.
Basically, the crust
of it is, don't
use the connections too long.
And if you do this
sufficiently often,
you will eventually get
a uniform distribution
of connections.
However, there is
an easier answer,
which is to use
container-native load balancing.
So with network endpoint point
groups and Google Cloud load
balancer, the load balancer
sees every pod backend
as an independent entity.
In this case, even you have a
very skewed set of connections
from the load balancer
to the backend,
the load balancer can look
at that, look at the request
and send it to the
least utilized backend.
And finally, one final
thing is this problem really
can crop up anytime
you use an L4 service
type with connections,
and you have this kind
of aggressive connection reuse.
So this is one
thing to watch for.
And this is container of
native load balancing,
you'll have a nice even
distribution of requests.
Now in addition to
accurate load balancing,
when your LB knows about
your backends directly,
you will have accurate
health checks.
You won't have the double
hop through kube proxy,
and you'll have much much
better visibility in debugging.
For example, when you
go dump your traffic,
you'll see the traffic
go directly from the load
balancer to your backend.
Nothing in between.
No tracing needed through
kube-proxy or IP tables.
Now finally, in terms
of scalable services,
we should talk about failures.
So the common way to
think about failures
is to think about
failure domains.
And in this case, we have
to think both about our data
and control plane.
What this means is that if
you have a single or maybe
multiple faults, they
won't cause disruptions
to your users.
Now, we could have failures
of, for example, a VM.
And if you have a
correlated failure where
all of your pods
of your application
are scheduled on the same VM,
then you may have an outage.
One way to avoid this is to
use scheduling constraints,
such as pod anti-affinity
to distribute
your pods across the
nodes in your cluster.
Another failure domain
you want to consider
is a zone old failure.
For example, in this case,
US West 1A has gone down.
To handle zonal failures, you'd
probably should do two things.
One for your data
plane, you should
have node pools that are
spread across multiple zones.
And for your control
plane, you will
want to use regional clusters.
Regional clusters gives you
a distributed control plane
across multiple zones
for your API servers.
Finally, we forgot
about one thing,
which is the config plane.
So not only do you have the data
plane and the control plane,
but you should be
careful that you can't
make that one edit to a config.
I know we all did it, and it
takes down your global network.
So ideally, you should have
separation here as well.
Separate your clusters by
namespaces or by clusters
for staging and production.
Make sure you stage a copy
of Kubernetes resources,
test, and then commit
the real thing.
So that's the
advantage of Kubernetes
is this declarative model
that can be checked in,
and you can run
CI/CD on your YAMLs.
In addition to thinking
about it at the sort
of cluster/namespace level,
you can also think about it
at the services level.
For example, if
you have a service,
you can use the Kubernetes
selectors to merge
multiple deployments together.
So you don't have that
one golden deployment
that you can edit and put
all your eggs in that basket.
OK.
So we've seen a couple
of best practices.
And now let's go over
what they actually look
like on a Kubernetes engine.
So first, we're
creating a cluster.
And as we recall, we want
multiple failure domains.
So we create a regional cluster.
Next, we know that we
want IP flexibility
in all the access all
the features, so we make
sure it's a VPC-native cluster.
And also we have sort of
know how our workload scales
with respect to
IPs, so we can set
a smaller maximum pods
per node to kind of save
on IP address usage.
Finally, we use
HTTP load balancing,
which is the Google ingress.
And we want a private
cluster, because we
want it to be secure.
And finally, we put ACLs using
master authorized networks.
So let's see what this looks
like when we make the cluster.
Can we switch?
OK.
So we have this cluster.
Right?
And we see that it
has three nodes.
In fact, all of
these three nodes
run across the
distributed control plane,
which is in a region US West 1.
And in fact, when we
look at our nodes,
we see that they use less
space than the default. Right?
Because we have
scaled our cluster
to be smaller IPs
per node, so we
can fit more nodes
into our network.
And also from the failure
domain perspective,
we see that it's actually
sharded across all of US1.
So if one of these zonal shards
goes down, we still are up.
Now let's look at the
container-native load balancer.
So this is a standard definition
for an application with a load
balancer.
We have the
deployment, which I was
speaking about earlier
with how you get
your workload in the cluster.
Then we have a service,
and the services
where we say we want to use
network endpoint groups,
which is the container-native
load balancing.
And finally, we expose the
application using ingress here.
Now, let's take a look at what
this load balancer looks like.
So here we have
the load balancer
that was created from that
snippet of configuration.
And you'll see that it's
split over three zones.
Right?
We have three zones
for reliability.
And in fact, when we
click into the zone,
we'll see that all of
my backends are my pods.
So I have very
accurate health checks
from the infrastructure
telling me
whether that
infrastructure, the load
balancer to that particular
pod directly is healthy or not.
All right.
So in summary, what were some
of the best practices for using
GKE in regards to networking?
Well, first, you should sit down
and understand your cluster IP
space and plan for
future growth and also
use VPC native clusters to
get the maximum flexibility
in terms of IP space planning.
The second thing is make
sure you understand what
your security requirements are.
But really, you should
be using private cluster
and master authorized networks
to secure your clusters.
Also tune your pod lifecycle
to avoid service disruption.
You know, handle sig term.
Make sure you respond correctly
to the readiness and health
checks.
Use container-native
load balancing
for the best performance and
visibility of your traffic.
And finally, understand
and plan for failures
on the three planes--
data, control, and config.
And your feedback is
greatly appreciated,
so please fill out the
survey app at the end.
MAHESH NARAYANAN:
And you can also
submit your questions for Dory.
[MUSIC PLAYING]